okay good wives don't leave no matter
what
I didn't do something outside let me let
me I'll give you please don't say please
I will give you I will give you
but good you know what
good wives believe in separations they
don't believe in divorce
um
what do you say separation you mean do
you mean legally basically living in the
same time
mentally like connect I'm actually
emotionally I I had that growing up I
grown up with my parents and I I know
that's normal to me actually no I have
to say that's more painful
they got divorced for me it was as a
child it was so much
you don't legally yeah but I I'm saying
I think but you live separate in two
different houses so that's basically the
same no sometimes you live in the house
yeah that's how we were we lived in the
house that's what happened to me
so tell me your thoughts do good wives
leave yes or no and good wives only
believe in separation they don't believe
in divorce
what do you think tell me why here
um I mean if you want to leave leave
honestly it doesn't make you a bad
person I just just leave like if I don't
know this or you're just not feeling
anymore like both of you it's a mutual
thing or okay just leave I don't believe
in that separation so a good wife can
leave
okay go ahead
uh yeah I do agree with you
um only because based of my personal
experience and watching my parents be
like that I always grew up wanting them
to actually get a divorce because it was
so damaging to us as children
so I feel like
life is way too short to stay in a
marriage with someone that you are not
happy with and to continue living a
miserable life yeah why why put yourself
through that why put your kids through
that as well if kids are involved as
well so I do think you can still be a
good wife but you can also leave maybe
do it for the kids yeah like well
because kids have better outcomes yeah
I'm saying stay together for the kids no
I don't like no that's even more no no
yeah but see I as I was the kid and I
always wanted my parents to get a
divorce I would even tell them but why
don't you guys get a divorce because it
was so painful seeing them be the way
they were with each other living that
separated life in the same house but how
do you how do you know it would have
been a better outcome for you you seem
to have turned out okay
right thank you so figure out what
appearance doesn't necessarily indicate
what's going on in the inside though
yeah exactly but I'm saying I've been
here like I don't know
um
every statistic statistic will tell you
it's better to have two parents in the
same house than it is
I know but then that kid also has to
deal with that trauma for example I have
trauma now growing up you may see me
like this but like you don't know how I
am inside like I have childhood trauma
now because of my parents marriage and
witnessing what went on in that house
because they did not uh get a divorce
did they not get along they would fight
a lot yeah absolutely they did not get
along and really and truly they should
have got divorced but because of the
kids they stayed and because my mom
believed in this whole I need to be a
good wife and I can't leave him now that
he's old and throw him out she stayed
but I wish she would have got divorced
because that was really painful as a
child growing up to see those things
what if one of them have moved out
though and you hadn't seen them as much
would that have been painful as well do
you think I think either way you would
that either way it would have been but I
actually would have preferred that if
they had got different house yeah I
would have liked my dad my dad's not
alive anymore
um but I would have liked it if he moved
out and we saw him on weekends or
something because I feel like it would
have been a healthier environment for us
kids I think it causes a divide and a
toxic household as well yeah it was an
extremely toxic household it was and it
was really hard growing up dealing with
that actually
um and it's also given me trauma now
that you know I'm in a relationship and
I'm planning to get married and I worry
that I'm gonna have the same life my mum
and dad had which is a horrible feeling
but that is what kids who go through
those things end up feeling when they
get to my age do you think that's me do
you look at
kind of marriage as a more kind of
solid thing now though you look at it
and you go I have to want this so badly
yeah before I get it's like I want to
break the generational curse now because
because it's a lot of women in my family
unfortunately left their husbands
um that's that at least that's a
positive outlook that you've got on it
you can look at it and be like yeah I
want to be a relationship that's yeah
that's strong and can hold together even
through hardship you can be like yeah I
don't want what happened before yeah
they said something you can kind of yeah
have you ever seen a healthy
relationship no I don't have a
representation of a healthy relationship
no so how how would you learn how to be
a wife
um I'm doing a lot of inner work like
I'm really searching inwards I
you know I've looked into therapy I I've
tried to work on myself I tried to work
on my traumas I really want to break
that generational curse
um so I have healthy open com you know
conversations with my mum about these
things in the past and her marriage with
my Dad we talk about these things on a
daily basis
um so I feel like I I have
I have the right mindset now because I
know what I don't want and I don't want
that unhealthy toxic environment that
unfortunately I grew up in as a child I
don't want my kids to go through that so
I feel like all the things that my mum
and dad went through I don't want to be
reenacting those in my marriage
um when it goes back to what you just
asked
um I agree with you
um I don't have any parents in my life
mom or dad
um I had a mom who played a woman and a
father
um but I think when it comes to
relationships and what you choose I
think it comes to choices and what you
learn I think the world I think that's
quite big to be honest but I think just
like learning from people around you you
just kind of sit back and be like do I
like that do I accept that
um and I think it's just Choice really
what makes you happy and you just build
yourself if that makes sense like with
me I think Love's beautiful I would like
I love that yeah I would love to get
married and it's not just marriage you
know I understand where you're coming
from it's like signing a paper and I get
where you where like you come from I
understand that but I feel like
there's someone out there for everyone I
agree you know yeah and I yeah I agree
with you and I think I would love to get
that opportunity maybe another country
why did you think that that why because
what was that I didn't even hear it
there's not there's not someone for
everyone
why yeah because some women die alone a
lot of women do they do all the time
some men die alone but how'd you know
they didn't have the love of their life
yeah oh and they lost it yeah because
one out of three men are because
[Laughter]
there's more women than men on the
planet so if every woman had someone
there would be eat 50 50. but there's
also yeah
there are people like me
there's there's a good question do you
see yourself sorry a bit topic but I'm
just quite curious would you do you see
yourself marrying a man or not like
again I would only ever get married if
that other person really wanted it but I
I've actually this is probably the first
time I've ever openly come out that's
very sexual
like publicly and but yeah I mean I yeah
either way if if it meant a lot to the
other person and I
you know felt like it I was in
possession in my life to be like if that
means so much to you I want to be able
to give that to you would you marry a
woman yeah yeah I mean
but I I again it wouldn't be because I
want even with the nagging
who here thinks I just want to raise a
hand who thinks good wives don't leave
you do everyone else thinks good wives
leave oh actually wait no good wives
will never leave good good wives you you
think that I don't think you're no
you're not a wife if you leave I think
if you sign up for something what do you
mean you're not you're no longer a wife
if you leave are you you're no longer so
so you're neither or someone else's wife
yeah but you're not in that situation
you're no longer the wife to be a good
wife
I'm just gonna I just kind of want to
break this down okay this is why men are
complaining it's like they maybe get one
meal from a good wife and she's she's
okay to leave if she feels like it and
we fight I mean he's okay to leave as
well like it's a two-way station
but the thing is we don't have anything
on the line if a man marries you you I'm
doing a documentary on the court system
here you you literally are paid like
lawyers um
you are you get a free counsel here if
you say that he abused you and you can
deny him access for his kids up to two
years trying to get like he doesn't have
a chance in court
no it's not Vice no no but vice versa
it's so much harsher on the man no it's
so it's so much harsher on the man to
the point ninety percent of the time
um women get custody yeah and it's
actually like it's actually a really
it's really sad I'm interviewing some of
the guys that have like been through it
it's
there are guys that haven't seen their
kid in four years because they're exac
accused them of abuse and they never did
it and there's no proof there's no
problem because there's no proof that
doesn't mean anything that doesn't it
doesn't mean that they do something okay
you think it's do you think it's okay to
deny access to children with no evidence
of a crime
no evidence they never press charges no
evidence I think it very much we should
just take take women's word amber
heard's word
that's another that's another thing
so it's like what are guys getting out
of this um
is it just um is it just what are you so
abused is it also like mental coercion
as well because and they're expanding
that's what they're doing they're
expanding the definition of abusive if a
girl says oh I want to buy two thousand
dollars worth of addresses and he says
now that he can put that under like
mental Financial coercion or something
or if he said if he said oh stop
following guys on Instagram or something
like that could be seen as manipulation
yeah it's really scary the more there's
this one story where the woman
um accused him of of touching the kids
and remember and remember remember
they're financially incentivized to do
that and then what they can do is they
go to Family Court and in family court
you don't actually have a jury to judge
you of your peers which you should be
entitled to and so they can go to Family
Court and deny you access to your kids
until they actually
um
finish yeah and that can take up to two
years so if he has a newborn he won't
see the kid for two years and she has no
punishment if she lied like this is what
Manner this is what men have to deal
with here and it's like well if she lied
honestly I feel like she should have
punishment that that should be but you
know what happened to him he killed
himself oh well but they but they women
do get punished for for example like I
don't really know but it's like she
accuses the man of like not in family
sexually assaulting no they don't and
family I'm telling you I've interviewed
the guys that they don't it's really sad
and so it's like the guys are like well
what do we get out of this and we can't
even like admit we can't even say what's
a good wife what's a bad wife
because everyone has their own
experiences their own interpretations
yeah but we know vaguely what's a good
husband what's a bad husband a husband
you wouldn't want a husband that like
doesn't protect you that if someone
tries to beat you up he's like oh go do
it yourself babe
we could say in generalities that women
like men want thin wives in general I
mean maybe slim thicker they're allowed
to say that they want to say that they
can say that right but I'm saying we
can't even say it they can't even get
three meals out of us for a good
remember I kept saying an A plus student
except except you
she she gives three meals
I like cooking so it's like there we go
I'm like you've got to like doing
something haven't you to be like it's
like the gym isn't it you've got to
enjoy it no actually no I mean I work at
it so I have to
I'm trying I'm trying with the gym shout
out to my boxing coach
I'm trying to remember I'm watching this
like good yeah sorry thank you all right
I'm gonna Read Super chats really quick
um also guys make sure you like the
video and let me know in the comments
what do you guys think Good Wife bad
wife what what do you think
um makes a good wife okay see Dumbledore
half of the girls over 30 are single and
childless the percent is rising every
year of the six girls on the show at
least three of you will die alone
I hope at this point I hope uh black
Moses Pearl stop being soft with these
women uh Manny F so Michelle Obama
should have left Barack Obama because
she hated him for 10 years out of their
30 years together follow me stop blaming
them and get counseling uh Scott and
Bradley a shout out to top producer a
shout out blessing
[Music]
uh black Moses um they can't answer
simple questions and they keep talking
about the exceptions women like them are
the reason guys get passwords fellas
invest in cat food and box wine um
battery buddies Logan his money is our
money my money is my money this is why
we don't care about your career or your
education ladies we don't get the
benefit at all we still need to earn
you'll notice no men are lining up to
date Oprah follow me you can still work
on your education which is more
important not your career a scouting
Bradley to a good man his wife and his
kids come first always brownie to the
panel do women now focus on imaginary
patriarchy just to distract themselves
from the fact they no longer know how to
be matriarchs as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible